Bonjour à vous curieuses et curieux !
Aujourd'hui, je vais vous parler de ça !
Et oui ! Figurez-vous qu'il y a des scientifiques qui font la même chose que dans notre générique,
mais en vrai.
Évidemment, il ne s'agit pas de peler
la Terre pour en faire des zestes,
mais pour voir ce qu'il y a à l'intérieur.
Et ça ressemble à ça !
Oui ce n'est pas forcément évident à première vue,
mais ce que vous venez de voir est une planète virtuelle,
semblable à la Terre,
réalisée par des chercheurs de l'observatoire de Lyon et de l'université de Sydney.
Oui ! Aujourd'hui on va parler de géologie et plus exactement de tectonique des plaques
avec des planètes virtuelles.
Et pour ceux qui suivent, c'est un sujet qui me tient particulièrement à cœur.
J'ai fait une thèse dessus.
Bon !
Reprenons depuis le début.
Si je vous dit : tectonique. Ça vous parle ?
Bon...
En fait pour les géologues, la tectonique,
c'est pas tout à fait ça.
La surface de la Terre est divisée en grands morceaux,
que l'on appelle des plaques tectoniques.
Sur certaines, il peut y avoir des continents,
mais pas sur toutes.
D'autres ne sont composées que d'océan.
Ces plaques se déforment peu.
Et vont bouger les unes par rapport aux autres.
95% de la surface de la Terre
est recouverte par de très grandes plaques tectoniques.
Comme par exemple, la plaque eurasienne,
où je me trouve actuellement.
Mais il y en a d'autres qui sont beaucoup plus petites,
comme la plaque ibérique
où il n'y a que le Portugal et l'Espagne.
C'est sûr qu'à l'échelle humaine ça reste grand.
¡ Muy grande !
En fait c'est un peu comme
si la surface de la Terre était un puzzle,
avec deux tailles de pièces très différentes.
Et les chercheurs se sont demandés...
pourquoi et depuis quand cette
différence de taille existaient.
Le problème quand on étudie la surface terrestre
c'est que plus on remonte dans le temps,
moins on a accès aux différentes pièces du puzzle.
En fait, on peut voir la Terre comme un
énorme système de recyclage.
Lorsque les plaques tectoniques
vieillissent et se refroidissent,
elles plongent sous la surface.
C'est la subduction.
On a donc deux problèmes.
Le premier, c'est que pour comprendre
pourquoi tout ça bouge,
il faudrait pouvoir regarder les
mouvements à l'intérieur de la Terre.
Ce qui est un petit peu compliqué.
Et le deuxième problème, c'est que les plaques disparaissent au fur et à mesure du temps.
L'idée est de pouvoir étudier l'évolution des plaques,
tout en sachant exactement
ce qu'il se passe sous la surface.
Malin !
Ces images représentent l'évolution
au cours du temps de la convection,
c'est-à-dire les mouvements,
les écoulements de masses chaudes et froides
dans les 3000 premiers kilomètres de
roches sous nos pieds.
A ce stade, certains auront tiqué.
Oui !
Je vous parle d'écoulement de roches !
WHAT !
En fait, c'est comme les glaciers.
Il faut juste se placer à la bonne échelle de temps.
Et ici, l'échelle de temps
c'est la dizaine de millions d'années.
Donc...
les roches...
ça s'écoulent !
Et ça c'est cool !
A la surface de leur planète virtuelle,
les chercheurs ont pu délimiter des plaques.
Et ils ont remarqué,
après plusieurs centaines de millions d'années,
la formation de deux types de plaques bien distincts.
Des grandes et des petites.
Comme sur Terre !
Et ils ont comparé ça, avec les mouvements qui ont
lieu à l'intérieur de leur planète virtuelle.
Les grandes plaques vont suivre
les grands mouvements de convection.
Et aux endroits où elles s'enfoncent,
la surface terrestre est soumise à de fortes contraintes.
Et elle va se fragmenter en petites plaques.
Un peu comme quand on découpe un brownie.
En surface, ça fait une flopée de petits morceaux
qui se distribuent autour du morceau découpé.
Voilà !
Donc grâce à cette recherche,
on en sait un peu plus sur la surface de la Terre,
et sur son évolution lors de la
formation de super continent.
Voilà...
Cet épisode très...
terre-à-terre...
est terminée...
Donc voilà... Ben !
Gardez les pieds sur Terre
OK ! C'est le moment de me taire.